This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the 20s. the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. I am so glad you are here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. today we are going to talk about quite a special 20-something experience one i think a lot of us perhaps are looking forward to maybe even fantasize about or perhaps it is your reality right now this is your current situation you're looking for some tips and a better understanding of the psychological experience that you're going through what are we talking about well we're talking about living alone in our 20s i think about 5 to 10 percent of 20s something year olds live alone and that is the highest in the population except for people over 60 who
often do so in the wake of a divorce or a separation or a death whereas people in their 20s are actively choosing this kind of lifestyle it's really a bit of a right of passage to say that you lived alone to have that experience of being completely responsible for your house to your space your life. It feels very adult. So beyond the days of living with family or friends. And it's also really scary. There are a lot of other factors that come into it. Loneliness, financial anxiety. It's strange really to be in your 20s and you still in many ways feel somewhat like a child. But when you transition to living alone, it is this very distinct sense of like, oh, this is the moment when I became an adult. Now I have to pay rent. Now I have to decide what to eat for dinner every night.
Whether the house gets cleaned or not, that's on you. And it's this level of responsibility, but also independence, that feels very serious and very sacred. I think living alone in your 20s is so much more than just getting to decorate your own space or recharging on your own, playing your music as light as you want. It is this very privileged journey that also contains a lot of psychological growth and answering a lot of core questions about who you are. Like how much social connection do I really need? What are the fears that I'm going to have to face when I'm not constantly surrounded by people? How am I going to pay all of my bills? Like everything in life, every decision we make, there are pros and cons. And I think underneath it,
there's even more psychology that is influencing our decision and our experience. And when it comes to living alone in your 20s, that is also the case. So that's what we're going to talk about today. Why, like, what are some of the things that people worry about? What are some of the concerns? But also what does psychology and some research have to say about many of the benefits? and how to successfully embrace the solitude of living alone so that you don't feel isolated, so that you don't feel overwhelmed, so that you don't feel, I guess, lonely. That's basically the agenda for today's episode. Now, this is coming at an amazing time for me.
Obviously, I pick the episode topics. So it's no coincidence that we're talking about this week because I draw so much inspiration for this podcast on my own own. life as someone who is right in the middle of their 20s. I have recently just moved into my own place after about almost eight years of living in uni accommodation and sharehouses. It has been the most liberating but also scary transition because it is this complete shift from always having someone around, someone to talk to, to being basically alone for like 70, 80% of the day. And especially because I work for myself and I work from home, I don't have the typical work
schedule, specifically like I don't have an office to go into every day. I don't have a regular work routine, regular exposure to colleagues and the same people. And that was a big source of fear for me in making this decision. I think the nature of working for yourself and then also living by yourself is that you're kind of denying yourself a great deal of incidental social interaction that most people would get from their nine to fives or their roommates. So I'm also someone who is very extroverted, which I know means I need a great deal more social interaction. You know, being an extroverted individual, I draw energy from others rather than from solitude. And it was definitely something I found
difficult both when I moved to Sydney and when I quit my full-time job last year. So I was not naive about the challenges and also my particular sensitivity to loneliness. I'm going to put it that way. However, I also knew at the time when I was making this decision that A, I needed the space, I needed more room because I was working, living, doing everything out of one tiny room in my old house and it was kind of beginning to blur the lines of like leisure and like sleeping and then like work time and also I wanted the freedom to do what I wanted with my own space keep it as clean or unclean as I wanted and more importantly it was that sensitivity and fear of loneliness that was actually both a consequence and somewhat of a benefit or an allure or a challenge for me for so long
probably since I was a child, I've had this intense dread about feeling lonely, not even about being lonely, and not even about being alone, but feeling lonely. And it's one of the things I fear most in the world to the point where it's highly irrational. It's probably more like a phobia, like autophobia. And it's kept me from doing a lot of things that I've wanted to do in my life. It's really paralyzed me at times. It's caused me to you bad friendships, stay in terrible relationships, say no to opportunities because I was terrified of what it would mean to be lonely in a new place, what that would mean for my mental well-being. And I think I'd had it in my mind that I wanted to live alone for a while. But the one thing that
was kind of standing in my way was, am I going to feel lonely? And I didn't want my fear of loneliness to prevent me from entering this next chapter, from entering this next chapter very much willingly. I had like a conversation with my boyfriend about this at the start of the year where we were basically like, do we just move in together? Because both our circumstances were changing. It just kind of seemed like the natural thing to do. But personally, I knew that I needed to have the experience of living alone for a year before living with him because, it was going to be this like perfect exposure therapy to solitude and getting comfortable in my own company and the silence that comes with it. I didn't want to, you know, move from living with
my parents to living with roommates to living with my boyfriend and never have experienced the space and the time to just be alone and what that experience would constitute and bring. I think if I was just to move in with him, which I definitely want to do in the future, I would just be using him as a crutch to avoid a very lifelong fear of mine. Also, when it comes to moving in with a partner, there is this really fascinating research paper from 2013 that just kept going over and over in my mind about the difference between sliders and deciders in relationships. So many couples slide into, rather than decide, these big decisions, these important life transitions, they slide into moving in together, they slide into getting
engaged, they slide into having kids. And what that means is that instead of making a conscious decision to do something, they do what is most convenient and what just seems like the next step rather than what might be best for their relationship. So using the example of moving in, this incredible article by psychology today talks about it like this. You know, it all starts with having a few pieces of clothes at your partner's place. We all have those, you know, a little drawer. That's next. Then you start staying over a few nights a week and then, you know, it's kind of more like five to six days. All your stuff is at there. house, you've got the dedicated drawer in the bedroom and the bathroom, and before realizing it,
and without actually having a thoughtful discussion, you basically ended up living together. And when someone's lease is up for renewal, it just kind of seems easiest to just officially move in together. Even though at no point have you made a conscious decision, you've slided, you've slid into this reality, you've slid into this present choice that you're making. Now, sometimes this is the best decision, and I'm sure me and my partner would be fine if we live together because we've had serious discussions about it. We know that we want to do it. But often the easiest decision is the one that requires the least deliberate and conscious choice. And that was the case with moving in together.
It would be easiest because we would save on rent because we already basically lived together, all of these things. But I didn't want to kind of wake up in five years and be like, hey, like, did we actually? actually choose our relationship? Do we actually choose our current reality? Or was it just a whole bunch of easy choices? And this can lead to what the authors of this paper call relationship inertia or insecurity, whereby because you've made all these easy decisions without thinking about them, you're suddenly at a point where you're in too deep and you feel like you can't start again. Once you live together, well you may as well get a pet. And once you have a pet, well, don't most people, you know, get engaged and then they have a wedding and then they have kids.
Suddenly you're at this point where you've never really made a conscious decision when it comes to these big life choices and decisions. And that was like a huge thing that was going on in my brain when I was making the decision to live alone was like, I really want my relationship to last. And so this living by myself, although it doesn't feel like our relationship is speeding up, it's probably going to give it more room to grow into the future because it's going to allow me to be my own person independently in this moment, in this time when I want to have more kind of experiences and moments of solitude. And it's going to mean that when we are ready to move in together,
we are like fully ready. We're fully committed to the idea. So living alone actually worked out well. My boyfriend was actually able to move into my old place, which is just like the best. coincidence. There are some other factors that motivated me, and I'm sure others to want to live alone in their 20s as well. The biggest one is freedom. You're at this point where the things that you used to feel very nonchalon about, like your sleep schedule, your routine, the messiness of your living environment, even the temperature of your house, the noise, all of those things now suddenly feel very important. I think that is a big transition in our mid-20s in particular, that shift from being very chaotic and easygoing and accepting of these things and, you know,
not really having any non-negotiables when it comes to our living space to being very serious about them and recognizing their importance for our mental well-being and no longer willing to make compromises in a shared living situation. When I was 19 living at uni, I didn't care if I went to bed at 10 p.m. or 2 a.m. I didn't care if someone's music was keeping me up. I didn't care if my kitchen was a mess. Now, though, I cannot imagine getting less than eight hours sleep. I don't want to live in filth because I have stuff to do and I want to be my best for that and that means having more control over my living environment. And this really highlights the importance of agency in controlling our environment, especially when it comes to our mental well-being. Your home is your place of comfort and
security. It fulfills a very deep psychological need we have for safety and belonging. When that is compromised by people who also share that environment and don't have the same values, don't respect your space, don't respect your boundaries, maybe your living styles are just not aligned. That can be really difficult and honestly very stressful. We actually talked about this in our episode on roommates and share houses, but when you don't feel like you can relax or do what you need to do in your home, it is a huge cumulative stress factor. It means you begin to become very avoidant of your living environment. You don't want to go home. You don't want to use the communal spaces. And that creates a lot of stress, a huge cortisol spike, because you never actually have the opportunity
or the space to relax. It puts a strain on your relationship. It puts a strain on your health amongst so many other things. So I don't think it's a surprise when we hear people say, you know, the reason I live alone is I just didn't want to live with roommates anymore. I was done sharing a space, even if it costs me more. There's also the fact that when you live with other people, the responsibility to maintain a house is diffused across a number of people, sometimes two, sometimes even four or five.
That diffusion creates a bit of a morality crisis. where no one wants to do the chores because they know that no one else is going to do them. And so why would they do them if no one else is going to do them? But then everyone has that belief. It's called the tragedy of the commons whereby when we have this common space, this shared asset like a home, like a living environment, everyone benefits from using it more and from, you know, keeping it clean, but no one wants to be the first one to do so.
So I think that after a while you get pretty fed up with that being the case and it's time to, you know, pursue an environment where you are the only one who benefits and the only one who has to contribute. Now, there was another thing that I said here that I think is important and that is you're prepared to do that even if it costs you more. There is something to consider in that and that is the contribution of the contribution of, feeling financially secure in our decision to live alone. If you've had a big income increase, one of the main ways you want to spend that money is where you spend your time, i.e. your home, your living environment. And with increased financial freedom, we might be more persuaded by kind of the luxury of having our own space. And it is definitely a luxury in this day and age.
Cost of living is no joke. I think I was going to inspections for one-bedroom apartments that were in, you know, almost unlivable, and they were upwards of $3,000 a month. And then, you know, you don't even get that because people often offer more because there are such a shortage of viable properties in so many cities around the world. And I think that we have to be careful in those situations where, of course, we are willing to make the decision consciously that we are going to pay more to have the luxury and the benefit and the liberation and the freedom of living by ourselves. but slowly what we see is ourselves pushing up that budget by $10, $20, $50,
and trying to find ways to justify that because we are so enamored by the idea of having our own space and having all that freedom that we don't actually consciously or deliberately think about how much money we are really spending. And that raises an important experience, an idea that I see a lot amongst fellow people in their 20s, It's this idea known as a lifestyle creep, which we are seeing more and more of, especially due to increasing inflation. So lifestyle creep is this common pattern of spending more money as you earn more money, but actually spending more proportionately on things that you don't really need.
Now, I am not a finance expert, although I do actually have an economic story, which is a little known fact. And when I was studying economics, there was so many applications. to psychology. And one of those applications is these cognitive biases that cause us to spend more money than we actually want to. It's like this set of illusions that makes us feel more comfortable with spending money that if someone walked up to you on the street and said, give me $1,000, you're not going to give them $1,000. But you would happily give away $1,000 for something that you really want, even if it doesn't bring you the same level of happiness as it would to do something else with that money. That is an example of an illusion that creates overspending. And lifestyle
creep is a combination of those illusions, including a restraint bias, having more and therefore wanting more and spending more. Also the overconfidence bias, whereby once you start making a certain amount of money, you think you'll always be able to make that same amount or even more. And that causes you to start spending based on what you believe your future income is going to be, not what you currently have. Lifestyle creep, it typically occurs after someone, you know, gets a raise or you get a new job with a higher income, you pay off some debt. We see more money in our bank account and we spend it, especially on discretionary items. And that seems very natural, right? But lifestyle creep is also known as silent inflation. A hundred thousand dollars now is not the same as
$100,000 five years ago. It is still a lot of money. But when we first start working, perhaps that was five years ago, four years ago, we normally had the expenses that we had during uni. So our income felt very proportionate to what we wanted to spend money on. As our income is slowly increased, as has how many nicer products we get, name brand products we get. And because of an increased cost of living as well, when we started working, perhaps our career goal was to make it to 100K. That does not have the same buying. And power as it did five, six, seven years ago. So we're actually spending from a place of delusion, spending from a place of cognitive bias and not clearly seeing how we're spending money.
Another illusion of this kind is known as the present bias, which means exactly what it sounds like. Many people make spending decisions based on the present without thinking of the future. they only want to fulfill their current urge or desire. In this case, you might be really invested in the idea of living alone, of having your own space, even if it means that you might jeopardize your long-term ability to save by spending more on rent than you are actually prepared to do, or it might mean that, you know, you're so invested in this idea of having this experience of living alone, that you don't realize that you can really only afford it for a year before you have to go back to share.
a house. That can get us in some trouble, but ultimately if you follow the rule that your rent should not be more than a third of your income, I always like to stick to a quarter just to be safe, then you should be okay. I think it's very easy to get wrapped up in the romantic version of what living alone could be, you know, could look like for us. I'm definitely someone who got very wrapped up in that idea before I did it, especially when we see so many depictions in TV shows and movies. Carrie Bradshaw from Saxon City is the prime example. Also people online who just seem to be absolutely living the dream. It's easy to get carried away in that, but I also think we need to be quite skeptical.
So I want to talk about some of the potential downsides slash factors for your consideration and also some of the solutions to those factors and those problems after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crime. crack.
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking.
Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid?
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Whilst I was applying for places to live, which was a nightmare in itself, just given the general
lack of housing, affordability and security in major cities, whilst I was doing that, though, the main thing, things, plural that people asked me about were, aren't you scared you'll get lonely, how are you going to afford this and aren't you scared? What about personal security? What if someone breaks in? There's no one to help you. These all get to our major fears about living alone, real or perceived. And what it is, what it comes down to is security, having enough of what we need when we want it, whether that's social interaction, money or safety, feeling like we are able to fulfill our very basic desires and like kind of basic needs. Like we need a level of social interaction. We need a level of money to survive. We need a level of security to sleep well at night.
The first one I think is the one that most people think of or are scared of, which is what the solitude of living alone might bring. We need social connection. I think that's especially the case in our 20s when so many of our lifelong social bonds are full. we are so used to being surrounded by people, or at least seeing depictions of this being the case. Social isolation and loneliness pose risks to health and well-being. We know that very well. And some studies even suggest it can be as life-limiting as behaviors like smoking. We have evolved to be creatures who need community in order to exist, survive and thrive.
So when we don't have easy access to that, it can bleed into all other areas of our lives. I think equally, each of us has a different threshold for the level of daily, maybe weekly, interaction that we need. That threshold is highly subjective and it's determined by a number of factors including extroversion versus introversion, but also what you're used to, your baseline level or need for interaction. I am someone who has a high threshold that I need to meet to feel satisfied, meaning that I understand, and I understood before I moved into my own place,
that I was going to need to see people at least like four to five times a week. If you are moving from a huge community of friends in a big sharehouse where you all get along and do everything together, your base on your threshold is going to be really high and it's going to be really disturbed by a move like moving into a place, an apartment on the other side of town. And the effects of that are going to be more drastic than someone who is living alone in the same neighborhood as their friends or who maybe went from living
with just one roommate who they weren't really close to to living alone. It's all really based on your circumstances. However, I think it's a big misconception that being by yourself means that you are inherently lonely just because social interaction isn't as convenient to you. Community doesn't need to exist all in the same place or space to be fulfilling. One of the major things I considered when moving into my own place was whether I had the community to sustain this decision, whether I was comfortable enough in my friendships, that I knew they could support me through what would be maybe a difficult adjustment period. Given that I wasn't, you know, best of friends with my old roommates as lovely as they are, and that all my close friends were already, like,
从只和一个其实并不太熟的室友合租，到开始独自居住。这一切其实都取决于你的实际情况。然而，我认为有一个很大的误区，那就是认为独居就意味着你生来孤独，仅仅因为社交互动对你而言没那么方便。社群并不需要全部存在于同一个地方或空间才能带来充实感。我搬进自己家时考虑的主要事情之一，就是我是否有足够的社群来支撑这个决定，我的友谊是否足够深厚，让我确信他们能在可能相当艰难的适应期支持我。鉴于我和前室友并非那种最好的朋友（尽管她们人非常好），而且我所有亲密的朋友都已经，
beyond my home environment, I felt more comfortable making this choice. many people who live alone are not socially isolated or lonely. In fact, people who live alone across all ages are actually typically more connected to other people. That's what one sociologist, his name is Aaron Kleinberg. He discovered this. He was doing a lot of research into this for his book, Going Solo, trying to dispel the idea that living alone meant that you were lonely. And what he realized is that people who live by themselves have an incentive to be
超出了我的家庭环境，我做这个选择时感到更加安心。许多独居的人并没有遭遇社交孤立或感到孤独。事实上，各个年龄段的独居者，通常反而与他人联系更紧密。这就是社会学家阿伦·克莱恩伯格（Aaron Kleinberg）所发现的。他为自己的书《独居时代》（Going Solo）对此进行了大量研究，试图消除“独居意味着孤独”这种观点。他意识到的是，独自生活的人更有动力去
deliberate about when they see people, the frequency and the quality of those interactions. That means they get more out of the times they do see people and they're actually energized by those situations rather than having these like incidental run-ins with people in their house, seeing the same people all the time and those interactions not necessarily being completely fulfilling, not giving us a lot of energy, but they're just there, right? I imagine this of like I'll use the roommate example again. You know, you might feel like you're seeing people more because you are seeing people more frequently. You're running into them in the kitchen. You're watching a movie together. You're going to the grocery store. But the quality of those interactions might not be as
刻意安排与他人见面的人数、互动的频率以及质量。这意味着他们能从与他人的会面中收获更多，并且这些经历实际上会为他们注入活力，而不是像在家里那样与人偶然碰面，天天见到相同的人，而那些互动未必能完全带来充实感，也无法给我们提供太多能量，但它们就摆在那里，对吧？我可以用室友的例子来想象一下。你知道，你可能会觉得你见人的次数变多了，因为你见面的频率确实更高了。你在厨房里撞见他们。你们一起看电影。你们一起去杂货店。但这些互动的质量可能并不如
good as if every second night you went and had like quality, serious quality time with a friend of yours. One challenge though is to actually give yourself the time to be alone. We often face a lot of pressure to constantly on and to be really filling our time with social activities when we live alone, to always have external stimuli. But embracing moments of solitude is important. Otherwise, you're not going to see the benefits of this decision. You still need to recharge your batteries, to tap into your creativity, to sit with yourself as much as you would need to do if you lived with other people. I think our basis for believing we will feel lonely if we live alone comes from a lot of studies on people who perhaps are a lot older than their 20s or on people who didn't feel like they
每隔一天抽出高质量、真正优质的时间和朋友相处来得好。不过，面临的一个挑战是真正给自己独处的空间。当我们独自居住时，常常面临很大的压力，要求自己时刻保持在线，用社交活动填满时间，总是需要外部刺激。但是，拥抱独处的时刻是很重要的。否则，你将无法看到这个决定带来的好处。你仍然需要为自己充电，激发创造力，像与其他人一起生活时那样，好好与自己相处。我认为我们之所以认为独居会感到孤独，是因为很多研究对象可能是远超二十多岁的老年人，或者是那些觉得
had a choice in living alone. Maybe they had to move into their own place after a breakup or an unexpected divorce or death. When we go and look at studies that actually take into account people's preferences for their living environment, whether they want to live alone or with other people, and they match those preferences to their reality, we see something very different. We see that in particular, people who are living alone because they want to live alone, and very different from those who are living alone reluctantly. They are a lot happier, they see a lot more of the mental health and emotional health benefits compared to someone who feels like they're living.
自己对独居没有选择权的人。也许他们是在经历分手、意料之外的离婚或丧亲之后不得不搬进属于自己的地方。当我们去查看那些真正将人们对居住环境的偏好（是想独居还是与他人合住）考虑在内，并将这些偏好与现实进行匹配的研究时，我们就会看到截然不同的结果。我们发现，尤其是那些因为“想独居”而独居的人，与那些被迫独居的人有着天壤之别。他们要快乐得多，与那些觉得自己在
living alone because they don't have a choice. I also think, actually I know from personal experience that one big myth we have about loneliness is that it's something that happens to us and we have no control over it. I think that's also incorrect. We have a lot more control over our experience of loneliness whether we fear it or run towards it than we think. And people who live alone often have a better relationship with that feeling because they understand, firstly, that it's something you have to get comfortable with, that sometimes it's unavoidable, and secondly, that loneliness is nothing more than a signal to reach out and connect. The same way hunger tells us to eat or thirst tells us to drink. People who live alone know it's true meaning. They know that it's just a messenger, and therefore
因别无选择而独居的人相比，他们能体会到更多的心理和情感健康益处。其实根据我个人的经验，我也知道，关于孤独的一个大误解是，认为它是降临在我们头上、我们对此毫无控制力的东西。我认为这也是不对的。对于孤独的体验——无论是畏惧它还是迎难而上——我们拥有比想象中更多的控制权。独居的人通常能与这种感觉建立更好的关系，因为他们首先明白，这是你需要去习惯的感受，有时它是不可避免的；其次，孤独不过是一个提醒你去寻求联系和沟通的信号。正如饥饿提醒我们进食，口渴提醒我们喝水一样。独居的人知道它的真正含义。他们知道它只是一个信使，因此
they initiate more protective actions like making weekly plans, joining a social, sport team compared to those who may have inbuilt company. It doesn't mean it doesn't get lonely at times. The first night I spent alone in my new place, I was super anxious and felt super odd and super strange, but everything is a trade-off. Sometimes you have to lose something to gain something better and I think that applies to everything in life, not just our living environment. You might lose convenience and a certain baseline level of social interaction.
相比于那些身边天然有伴的人，他们会采取更多保护性的行动，比如制定每周计划、加入社交或运动团队。这并不意味着独居时从不感到孤独。我在新家度过的第一个夜晚，感到超级焦虑、超级怪异、超级陌生，但每件事都有得有失。有时你必须失去一些东西才能得到更好的东西，我认为这适用于生活中的一切，而不仅仅是居住环境。你可能会失去习惯了的便利性以及某种基准水平的社交互动，
and run-ins that you're used to, but you also gain a lot of freedom and independence. It's about recognizing which of those things is more important to you, which of them you value. It also means that you're going to have people over whenever you want for as long as you want. They can have a sleep over. No one, you don't need to get anyone's permission. It actually might even make seeing your friends easier because you can do it in the environment that you want to do it in without having to ask other people. I also think that in that solitude, even when you don't have people around, you get to me more authentic, more responsible, more conscientious, perhaps even more feeling, more in touch with your emotions because there are less distractions that you can go and seek out.
以及那些你习以为常的碰面，但你也收获了大量的自由和独立。关键在于认清这些事情中哪一件对你更重要，哪一件是你所珍视的。这也意味着你可以随时邀请任何人来家里做客，想留多久就留多久。他们可以留宿。不需要得到任何人的批准。这甚至可能让见朋友变得更轻松，因为你可以在自己想要的坏境中与他们相聚，而不必去询问别人的意见。我也认为，在这种独处之中，即便身旁空无一人，你也会变得更加真实、更有责任心、更有意识，甚至情感更丰富，对自己的情绪更敏感，因为你可以主动去寻求的分心事物变少了。
So now that we've dispelled some of the fears, talked about some of the, perhaps downside, some of the things that we've been told to be wary of when it comes to living alone, I actually want to give you some final tips for doing this successfully. how can we successfully embrace solitude, embrace like the absolute luxury and privilege of getting our own space, of having this freedom, of having this independence, of having this, you know, time and this moment to unwind, to really learn ourselves better. Some of these tips are psychological, but they're also practical because that is the balance we always like to strike. And I've gotten these from other people that I know who've been doing this a lot longer than I have, but also just from my recent experience and what I found has been helping when I felt lonely, when I felt a little bit scared, when I felt a little bit overwhelmed.
既然我们已经消除了部分恐惧，谈到了一些可能存在的负面影响，以及我们在被告知独居时需要警惕的事情，我其实想给大家一些成功做到这一点的最终建议。我们如何才能成功地拥抱独处，拥抱拥有自己空间的绝对奢侈和特权，拥有这种自由、这种独立、这种（你知道的）能够放松、能够真正更好地了解自己的时间和时刻？其中一些建议是心理层面的，但它们也很实用，因为这是我们一直喜欢达到的平衡。这些建议来自于我认识的比我更有经验的其他朋友，也来自于我最近的经验，以及自我感到孤独、有点害怕、有点不知所措时发现真正管用的方法。
Firstly, create a routine. Having a daily routine can provide structure and stability, and that reduces feelings of uncertainty. Uncertainty is a big source of stress, especially when you're in a transitionary period of having just moved in. Everything else feels new and sometimes you need something to feel consistent. You need something to commit yourself to so that you don't just feel wrapped up in a lot of the fear. It could be a weekly routine, not even a daily routine, one that, you know, hopefully involves something social like Mondays I go to run club, Tuesdays are my chill day, Wednesday I make plans to see a friend, etc., etc. So you're not stressed about being forced to be alone or being forced to feel bored when you don't have to because
首先，建立一个日常规律。拥有日常作息可以提供结构感和稳定性，从而减少不确定感带来的焦虑。不确定感是压力的主要来源，特别是当你刚搬完家正处于过渡期时。其他一切都感觉是崭新的，有时你需要一些能带来持续感的东西。你需要让自己有所承诺，这样就不会只被满腔的恐惧所裹挟。它可以是一个每周的常规安排，甚至不必是每日的，比如（希望其中包含一些社交活动）周一我去跑步俱乐部，周二是我放松的日子，周三我安排和朋友见面，等等、等等。这样你就不会因为被迫独处或在不必要时感到无聊而感到压力，因为
you know that you have some structure to your days, some structure to your weeks. Secondly, and this is probably my favorite tip, build community in as many ways as possible, even if it feels small. I think we often think of community as having a huge network of friends that we call on every single day, but actually going to the same grocery store, going to the same gym class, the same time, each week, the same cafe, introducing yourself to your neighbours. Those are important social touch points that are really valuable and protective and provide that necessary sense of belonging, even if you don't have a large network of friends. Even if you are in a huge city, it's nice to feel seen, to feel like you exist, even if you aren't seeing people as much
你知道你的日子和星期是有一定结构和安排的。其次，这很可能是最受我喜爱的建议，尽可能通过多种方式建立社群，哪怕这种社群感觉很小。我认为我们经常把社群看作是一个庞大的朋友网络，我们可以每天呼叫他们，但实际上，每周同一时间去同一家杂货店、去同一个健身班、去同一家咖啡馆、向邻居做个自我介绍。这些都是重要的社交触点，它们非常有价值、具有保护性，并能提供必要的归属感，即便你没有庞大的朋友圈。即便你身处超级大都市，那种被看见、觉得自己存在的感受也很美好，哪怕你并没有像自己希望的那样
as you'd like. And it just, honestly, it's such a positive experience to be able to be like, oh, have your neighbor's number, text them for a cup of sugar, go and knock on their door to tell them you're having people over, invite them for a wine. It actually was a huge part of my, when I first moved to Sydney, was being super friendly with my neighbors. And they were so, so lovely. And it was so nice to sometimes be walking back from the train after a really long day
经常见到人们。老实说，能够有邻居的电话号码，发短信借一杯糖，去敲他们的门告诉他们你家里来了客人并邀请他们喝杯酒，这真是一种非常积极的体验。这其实是我刚搬到悉尼时的一个重要部分，当时我和邻居们处得超级友好。他们真的非常好。有时在经历了非常漫长的一天工作后，
at work, feeling like I didn't belong. and just there's someone there who knows who you are who's going to wave high to you while they're going up the street. I also think be open with your friends when you are feeling lonely. I think we tend to feel a lot of embarrassment and shame and that prevents us from putting a label on this feeling and acknowledging it to others around us. It's interesting that when you are the first one to open the door and say, hey, I've been feeling super lonely, I've been feeling super off, I really want to connect. How many people are going to say the exact same thing. How many people are going to be like, oh my gosh, I've been feeling the same way. I can't believe that we've both just been existing in these
拖着疲惫的步伐从火车站走回来，感觉自己与这个世界格格不入，而就在那里，有一个人认识你，在街上走过时会向你挥手打招呼。我也认为，当你感到孤独时，要对朋友坦诚。我们往往会感到许多尴尬和羞耻，这阻止了我们为这种感觉贴上标签并向周围人承认。有趣的是，当你成为第一个打开心扉说“嘿，我一直觉得超级孤独，觉得状态超级不对劲，我真的很想建立联系”的人时，会有多少人给出完全相同的回答。会有多少人说：“天哪，我也一直有这种感觉。真不敢相信我们两个竟然一直生活在这些
isolated little bubbles and like not reaching out. It's actually really nice, I think, to have these really, I think, dark and sad feelings of loneliness and then to feel seen in them and to bond with someone over the fact that you're both going through a very similar emotional state. From that conversation, you can make plans to see each other regularly. You can start to build that network. I do honestly think that people really value honesty and they value candor when it comes to these kind of things that we're normally taught to hide. So I think it's not just about being social.
孤立的小气泡里，却彼此没有联系。”我认为，拥有这种黑暗而悲伤的孤独感，然后在这种感觉中被看见，并因为两人正在经历非常相似的情感状态而产生共鸣，其实是一件非常美好的事。从那次对话开始，你可以计划定期见面。你可以开始建立那个社交网络。说实话，我真的认为人们在面对这些我们通常被教导要隐藏的事情时，是非常看重诚实和坦率的。所以我觉得这不仅仅是为了社交，
It's not just about always having plans because we don't want to overcomit ourselves. It's about just being honest with the people around you when you just want to talk more. You want to text more throughout the day. you just want to be in contact more often. I'd also say find ways to cherish this time and cherish this silence. I always think about how one day I want to be married, I want to have kids and there will be a moment when I will probably wish for more days alone by myself in my own space doing exactly what I want.
这不仅仅是为了总是把日程排满，因为我们不想让自己承载过多。这只是关于在你想多聊聊天时，对周围的人保持诚实。你想在白天发更多短信。你只是想更频繁地保持联系。我还要说，要找到珍惜这段时光和珍惜这份安静的方法。我总是幻想着有一天我能结婚，有自己的孩子，到那时，我可能会无比渴望有更多的日子能独自待在自己的空间里，做着自己完全想做的事。
And that time that I'm wishing for in the future is right now. This is the moment and that future projection of me keeps me more grateful for the present, knowing that there might be one day where all I'll ask for is to come back. This one's a lot more psychological, but it's also important to make your space your own and to make it feel cozy and a place that you actually want to be in. Our living environment and our mental health are intrinsically related. That's something that we don't talk about a lot in the psychology and kind of self-help mental wellness space. Cluttered spaces can create feelings of being overwhelmed.
而我现在正在祈求未来的那种时间，就是现在。当下就是那个时刻，对未来的这种设想让我对现在更加充满感激，因为我知道也许总有一天，我唯一的祈求就是能够回到独处的状态。接下来的这一条更偏向心理层面，但同样重要，那就是把你的空间打造成真正属于你自己的地方，让它感觉温馨舒适，成为一个你真正愿意身处其中的场所。我们的居住环境与心理健康有着内在的紧密联系。这是我们在心理学和自助心理健康领域不常讨论的话题。杂乱的空间会带来不知所措的感受
and anxiety whilst tidy spaces invoke a sense of calm. Having colors and objects in your environment that are meaningful, that are bright, that can really boost your mood. Even things like lighting, temperature, sound, smells, the color palette again, those are all really important factors to make you feel comfortable, relaxed, and to feel almost safe. You know, harsh lighting, loud noises that leads to a lot of anxiety or agitation. you know, dark and cold spaces can make you feel unmotivated or miserable. It's why I think people like myself really like the idea of having a lot of warm light
和焦虑，而整洁的空间则能唤起一种平静感。在你的环境中摆放有意义的、明亮的色彩和物品，真的可以提升你的情绪。甚至像照明、温度、声音、气味、色彩搭配这些，也都是让你感到舒适、放松甚至感到安全的非常重要的因素。你知道，刺耳的灯光、巨大的噪音会导致许多焦虑或烦躁；昏暗冰冷的房间会让你感到毫无动力或痛苦。这就是为什么我认为像我这样的人真的很喜欢拥有大量温暖光线的感觉。
in your living space, filling it with rugs, things that are going to be creature comforts for you that are going to make you want to come home, make you want to relax, make you want to enjoy this solitary space that you've created that is all for you. finally let's talk again about financial insecurity and financial anxiety because it is a huge factor especially when you have like a massive transition from maybe paying a lot less rent to a lot more rent those first early weeks we have to buy the fridge you have to buy the washing machine you have to buy all new furniture it is a huge shift it's a huge change don't fall into the pattern of avoidance in response to feeling like your finances are out of control.
在你的起居空间里，塞满地毯、各种能给你带来精神慰藉的物品，让你渴望回家，想要放松，想要享受这个为你自己打造的、完全属于你的独处空间。最后，让我们再次谈谈财务不安全感和财务焦虑，因为这是一个巨大的因素，尤其是当你经历从支付较少房租到支付巨额房租的巨大转变时，在最初的几周里，我们必须买冰箱，必须买洗衣机，必须买所有全新的家具，这是一个巨大的转变，这是一个巨大的改变，不要在觉得财务失控时陷入回避的模式。
Avoidance is an unconscious defense mechanism that our brain adopts when it isn't ready to engage or acknowledge a difficult situation or feeling. Even though we know in our rational minds, by looking away, it's probably going to get worse. That is a huge sign that you might be experiencing financial anxiety if you are refusing to open your bills when you get them. If you are refusing to pay them on time, refusing to pay certain debts off because you don't want to see the money leave your account. Another sign of financial anxiety is rigidity, compulsively budgeting, needing to know where every dollar is going, whether you can get a better bang for your buck to the point where you don't actually buy things you need,
回避是一种无意识的防御机制，当我们的大脑还没准备好面对或承认困难的处境或感受时，它就会采用这种机制。尽管我们在理性上知道，视而不见可能会让情况变得更糟。如果你收到账单却拒绝打开，那可能就是你正在经历财务焦虑的一个巨大信号。如果你拒绝按时支付账单，因为不想看到钱从账户里划走而拒绝偿还某些债务。财务焦虑的另一个迹象是刻板，强迫性地做预算，需要知道每一块钱花在哪里，是否能物超所值，甚至到了不买必需品的程度，
like food, or you won't use the heater or the aircon, even when you desperately need it. This, This compulsive rigidity and obsessiveness is probably a sign that your worries are serious concerns and really infiltrating other parts of your life. You may value the freedom of living alone, but I don't think it's freedom if you're depriving yourself of your basic needs. There is no shame in reassessing your finances and realizing that the lifestyle you currently have might not be one that you can afford right now, just at this moment, maybe in the future, but right now you might need to make a bit of a shift.
比如食物，或者即使你极其需要，也不愿意开暖气或空调。这种强迫性的刻板和强迫症，可能表明你的担忧已经很严重，并且真正渗入了你生活的其他方面。你可能很珍视独居的自由，但如果你剥夺了自己的基本需求，我认为这就不是自由。重新评估你的财务状况并意识到你目前的生活方式可能是你现在这个阶段负担不起的，这并不可耻，也许在未来可以，但现在你可能需要做出一些调整。
There is no shame in that. There is no shame in going back to your former living situation. I know it can feel a lot easier to just put your head in the sand, but being honest with yourself about your financial situation is so important when you make the decision to live alone. Personally, some things that have worked for me is that I only ever use a debit card to make those big purchases. so I'm always aware of what money I can spend and I don't have to deal with credit card bills.
这并不丢脸。回到以前的居住环境并不丢脸。我知道把头埋在沙子里可能会感觉容易得多，但在决定独居时，对自己诚实面对财务状况是非常重要的。就我个人而言，对我管用的一些方法是，我只用借记卡来进行这些大额消费，所以我总是清楚自己能花多少钱，也不用去处理信用卡账单。
I have a budget that is realistic and not too strict. I found that this works because if I do go over it, which sometimes I do, very rarely, if I go over it, I don't suddenly feel like, well, okay, I've gone over it. Now I can just spend whenever I want. When I have a budget that is too stringent and too strict that is too confining, perhaps too harsh, It's so much easier to spend more and so much easier to then throw all ideas of like financial responsibility out the window because you've already failed at keeping the budget for that week. So make sure that you are actually realistic about what you want to spend money on,
我有一个切合实际、不太严苛的预算。我发现这样做很管用，因为如果我真的超支了（虽然有时会这样，但很少发生），如果我超支了，我不会突然觉得：“好吧，既然我已经超支了，现在我可以随心所欲地花钱了。”当我有一个过于严格、死板、束缚太多甚至有些严厉的预算时，花钱就更容易了，而且很容易把所有财务责任的概念抛到九霄云外，因为你已经在这个星期没有管好预算了。所以，请确保你对你想把钱花在什么上面有切合实际的认识，
what you need to spend money on and then what you desire to spend your money on. I also pay my rent from a high interest account. Every time I get paid, I put as much rent for my future as I can into that account. even if it's just two weeks, normally I like to do a whole month, and I cannot touch that money. It's this nice chunk that sits in this high interest account and accrues interest to put towards bills and things like that. Also, you just don't even realize how much that kind of builds up. I think you can make like 20, 50, 100 bucks from some of those accounts, obviously do your own research. Please do not just go out and do that if it's not what's best for you, but that was advice
你需要把钱花在什么上面，然后是你渴望把钱花在什么上面。我还会从一个高息账户里支付房租。每次我发工资，我都会尽我所能把未来要用的房租存入那个账户，哪怕只有两周，通常我喜欢存满一个月，而且我不能动用那笔钱。这是一笔很棒的资金，存在这个高息账户里并产生利息，用来支付账单之类的事情。另外，你甚至不会意识到这种积蓄增长得有多快。我想你从其中一些账户里可以赚到20、50、100块钱，当然，请自己做好调研。如果这不适合你，请不要盲目跟风去这样做，但这是我妈妈在我很久以前刚搬出去住时给我的建议，
that my mom gave me when I first moved out way back when and it's really stuck with me. Here's another fun tip. If you are buying new furniture, places like IKEA and some other big furniture stores, 90% of the time, someone is selling that exact thing that you want on Facebook marketplace. And maybe you'll have to pay to get it delivered, but that $50 extra that you're paying is saving you hundreds of dollars anyways. It's like 80 to 90% cheaper sometimes. I bought my desk this way. It was I think $170 brand new and I bought it for $25 in like off Facebook marketplace. IKEA also has a second hand section. You should go and look at that. There are so many good fines. I think you don't need to skimp. You don't need to not give yourself the things that you need
这个建议对我影响深远。这里还有另一个有趣的小建议。如果你在买新家具，像宜家和其他一些大型家具店，90%的情况下，有人会在Facebook Marketplace上出售你正好想要的那种东西。也许你得付运费，但你多花的50块钱无论如何也能帮你省下好几百块钱。有时候它能便宜80%到90%。我的书桌就是这样买的。全新的时候我想大概是170美元，我在Facebook Marketplace上只花了25美元就买到了。宜家也有二手区。你应该去看看。有太多好东西了。我认为你不需要吝啬。你不需要为了省钱而拒绝给自己需要的东西，
like a TV stand or a desk just because you're going to. You can't, you don't want to spend that huge amount of money. You just have to be smart. And you also have to really do your research in terms of how much is this going to cost? I think we just think like, great, I pay my rent every week. I can afford the additional rent? It's also, can I afford the additional utility bills? Can I afford to pay Wi-Fi on my own?
比如电视柜或书桌，仅仅因为你不想花那笔巨款。你只需要变得聪明一点。而且你还必须真正做好调研，弄清楚这到底要花多少钱。我想我们只是觉得：“太好了，我每周交房租。我能负担得起额外的房租吗？”问题还在于：我能负担得起额外的水电费吗？我能一个人负担得起Wi-Fi费用吗？
Can I afford all the expenses that are going to come with moving in, like a removalist fan, like buying boxes, like buying boxes, like buying, little knick-knacks that you need for a house, like a fruit bowl. I didn't know that I needed that. And I've never needed that. It's always been accessible to me in my previous homes. Toilet paper. At toilet paper stand, there's so many little expenses. Fight off any of those cognitive distortions that are trying to get you and convince you to spend more money and be realistic about what this is actually going to cost before you just become enamored with the idea. I think that is all that we have time for today.
我能负担得起搬家带来的所有开销吗，比如搬家货车、买纸箱、买各种房子需要的小玩意，比如果盘？我以前都不知道我需要这个。而且我以前从来不需要它。在我以前的家里，这些都是唾手可得的。还有卫生纸。一个卫生纸架，有那么多零星的开销。在你对独居的想法着迷之前，击退所有那些试图控制你、说服你花更多钱的认知扭曲，并对实际成本保持现实的评估。我想我们今天的时间就这么多了。
Thank you so much for tuning in whether you're thinking about living alone, whether you live alone, and you have any other advice from me. You know, I feel like I'm not yet an expert on this. I am fresh to the Living Alone, Living Solo Club. Please send through your tips, send through anything else that you want to share. I'm so excited to see what I learn. I'm so excited to just take everything that I can from this experience. I feel so lucky to be able to do this.
非常感谢大家的收听，无论你是在考虑独居，还是已经独自居住，并有任何其他建议想告诉我。你知道，我觉得我还不是这方面的专家。我是独居、单身俱乐部的新成员。请发来你的建议，发来任何你想分享的内容。我非常期待看到我能学到什么。我非常期待从这段经历中尽可能多地汲取营养。我觉得自己能做到这一点真的很幸运。
I never thought that this was going to be something that I did and this early in my life. I thought I was going to be, you know, my 30s before I got the chance to live by myself. But I am learning so much. I am experiencing so much and I am so grateful to everyone who has listened this past couple of years for really giving me this opportunity.
我从没想过我会做这件事，而且是在我这么年轻的时候。我以为我要到30多岁才有机会一个人住。但我学到了太多。我经历了太多，我非常感激过去几年里一直聆听节目的每个人，真正给了我这个机会。
It's all thanks to the podcast that I even have the flexibility and the financial freedom to be able to make this decision for myself. So thank you so much. I really hope you enjoyed this episode. If you did, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now, make sure that you are following along on Spotify or you are subscribed on Apple Podcasts. And if you have an episode suggestion, something you want to talk about, any further advice from me or anyone else for that matter, please feel free to message me at that psychology podcast. And we will be back on Friday with another.
这一切都要归功于这个播客，我才拥有了为自己做出这个决定的灵活性和财务自由。所以非常感谢大家。我真心希望你们喜欢这一期节目。如果你喜欢，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听节目的任何地方留下五星好评，确保你在Spotify上关注了我们，或者在Apple Podcasts上订阅了我们。如果你有任何节目建议、想探讨的话题，或是来自我或其他任何人的进一步建议，请随时在That Psychology Podcast给我发信息。我们周五会带着另一期节目回归。
episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了坚韧意志、体能锻炼的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性的方法。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWO%”。在《Look Back at it》播客节目中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是个重要的时刻。
84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences,
那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯带来的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，
having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士在进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次并进行推销，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人的模式。格雷格，一个同性恋，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。